a major prisoner swap has been completed
between Russia and Ukraine after a
months of talks we have been looking at
live pictures over the past hour of what
has been happening those prisoners going
from either side as you can see beside
me on screen we have eager chat enough
eager is at the venue cava or a port
International Airport just outside
Moscow where the Russians have touched
down there eager and bring us up the
date with spec who touched down who
indeed are some of the Russians that
were swapped today
well yunnan we finally got a
confirmation that this swap was 35
people for 35 people it's official 35
Ukrainians for 35 Russians they in fact
did touchdown just minutes ago about
half an hour ago I should say at an
airstrip a few hundred meters behind
that wall behind those gates behind me
and we already saw them walking down the
walking down from the airport all 35
people very very happy they are finally
home they are finally back in Russia
they've been waiting for this for a very
very long time among them again we do
not know all identities we do not know
the identities of all people but we do
know that among those 35 people exiting
the plane was Kirill Wyszynski he was
the head of the Ukrainian branch of
Russia's news agency RIA Novosti and in
Ukraine he was accused of state treason
and put in jail for the for that for the
time of the trial he wasn't he wasn't
found guilty or anything he was just put
in jail to wait for his trials and for
he spent there more than 400 days and
for all those days the Russian side was
adamant that a man not found guilty it
is by default innocent so he should not
spend that time behind bars and what I'm
saying this has been a long time coming
for Karel wyszynski I mean a long time
because because there have been so many
false alarms and this this swap it was
in the works for a very very long time a
very sensitive issue for both Russia and
Ukraine and in fact just weeks before
today before today swap Karel Wyszynski
was released from jail on bail and that
was
seen as a very positive sign for the
relations between Russia and Ukraine and
for all the prisoners for this
particular prisoner swap finally today
it happened now again we do not know
what's gonna happen whether or not all
those people all those 35 Russians are
going to just walk out of those doors
behind me or if they're gonna be boy or
if they're gonna board one particular
bus and they will be rolled out of these
gates now of course we're hoping to talk
to Stu any of them in fact to get their
stories as soon as possible and so I
will be here on standby to bring you the
latest and I mean everybody's here on
the tiptoes I mean when this bus passes
I hope I hope that my cameraman could
pan out for you just to show you some
just it's just half of the journalists
here of the journalists here who have
been awaiting you for Carroll wyszynski
and 34 other Russians I will be standing
by here together with them to bring you
all the latest yeah and that's the thing
each of those 35 Russians each have a
fascinating story to tell what a time it
has been for them and indeed now there
are families as they rejoin them Igor
thanks very much for now eager a [ __ ]
done off at Moscow's the new cover
Awards joining me now though in this
year for the other side of things also a
lot of happy people and families on the
Ukrainian side artis Donal quarter has
been following that following it as much
as we can of course no official
statement we've been looking at live
pictures and just trying to base the
peace meal together what's being
happening but just to confirm 35
Ukrainians are back yeah on Ukrainian
soil do we know much about them well
yeah we we know quite a bit at this
point but you know this just to go back
to this moment it with the Russian Human
Rights Commissioner called it a historic
moment and it definitely was one for
Ukraine even President Vladimir insky
made an appearance there to meet those
prisoners that were exchanged and he
gave a speech he said it was a new
chapter in relations between Ukraine and
Russia but he also said that it was the
first chapter in returning all of
Ukraine's prisoners who are in Russia
back to their
home country now going back to
identifying some of these prisoners that
were exchanged we don't have we haven't
identified all of them but it's been
confirmed that one very high-profile
person oleg sentsov who was sentenced to
20 years in prison for terrorist
plotting during the during the Crimean
referendum in 2014 he was in fact
released back he was identified coming
off of the plane he served five years
out of that 20-year sentence the Russian
government sentenced him for plotting to
blow up bridges and government
installations and things like that now
there also there's also the idea that
many of these Ukrainians that were
transferred back to Kiev may have been
sailors who were involved in the Kerch
Strait incident that happened in
November of last year now this just to
give our viewers a bit of background on
that this occurred in by the the Kerch
Strait between the Black Sea and the Sea
of Azov where three Ukrainian vessels
were trying to move and into the Sea of
Azov and the Russian Navy basically said
you need to turn back this is Russian
territorial water they didn't respond
and the vessels were seized after that
so Ukrainians sailors were taken
prisoner and many much speculation
suggests that a lot of those prisoners
if not all were on in involved in this
prison exchange we should point out as
well shouldn't we that this is happening
under a relatively new ukrainian
president he wasn't comedian he turned
to politics played president initially
the president in a TV show as well but
it comes after Petro poroshenko who was
seen as more perhaps hawkish yeah and
and a lot of war weary Ukrainians seem
to put their vote to this new president
I suppose hoping for a reset of
relations or at least more stability in
Ukraine yeah a lot of people see him as
the man that at least much more than
Petro poroshenko will be able to bring
better relations with Russia and this
speech he gave at the at the reception
for the prisoners seems to point in that
direction in which he said that this is
a new chapter of relations between
Russia
and and Ukraine and that it's only the
first in a longer dialogue about
prisoners
you